GREG DALESANDRE: Hi.
Welcome to the App Engine
Fireside Chat.
Apparently we have
a big firepit.
So I think what we'll do is--
the people who we are waving to
are members of the team, so
if you think we're waving to
you to come up on stage--
So we'll do a quick round of
introductions so you know who
all the people are on stage--
when I say quick,
pretty quick.
And then start to answer
questions from the audience.
Talk about topics that
you're interested
in us talking about.
Let us know what you think.
Please use the microphones
on the side so
that it can be recorded.
I guess I'll start intros, and
then I'll go to Alfred next.
So my name is Greg Dalesandre.
I'm a senior product manager
on App Engine.
ALFRED FULLER: I'm
Alfred Fuller.
I'm a software engineer on the
App Engine data store.
MATT WILDER: I'm Matt Wilder.
I'm a site reliability engineer
for App Engine.
BRETT SLATKIN: Brett Slatkin,
software engineer.
MAX ROSS: Max Ross, software
engineer on the data store,
Java run time, various
management function.
ALON LEVI: Alon Levi, software
engineer on the serving
infrastructure team and
various management
functions as well.
PETER MAGNUSSON: Peter
Magnusson, engineering
director, mostly management
functions, I guess.
SEAN LYNCH: I'm Sean Lynch.
I'm one of the product managers
on App Engine.
GUIDO VON ROSSUM: I'm
Guido von Rossum.
I'm a software engineer on the
tools team and I have an
opinion on everything.
ANDREW DURAND:: I'm Andrew
Durand, and I
work on the Go team.
MIKE AIZATSKY: I'm
Mike Aizatsky.
I'm a software engineer.
I produce files
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
NICK BURTON: I'm Nick Burton,
on the task queue team.
GREG DOCK: I'm Greg Dock, and
I"m on the task queue and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
team.
WESLEY CHUN: Wesley Chun,
Developer Advocate.
PETER MCKENZIE: Peter McKenzie,
engineering manager.
MICKEY KATARIA: Mickey
Kataria, I'm
another product manager.
ERIC MORRIS: Eric Morris, the
odd duck from sales and
business development.
JUSTIN HA: Justin Ha, serving
infrastructure, software engineer.
TOM EDWARD HAZEN: Tom
[? Edward Hazen, ?]
I do documentation.
MICHAEL HANDLER: I'm
Michael Handler.
I'm the tech lead for the site
realizing engineering team for
app engine.
GREG DALESANDRE: All right.
So this is actually a pretty
good portion of the
team you have here.
And so we're happy to talk about
the topics that you're
interested in us
talking about.
We could talk amongst
ourselves.
That might not be
as interesting.
Does anyone have any questions
or topics they want us to get
started with?
I heard something about
new pricing.
Yes?
MAX ROSS: Yes, there
is new pricing.
GREG DALESANDRE: So you might
have seen yesterday that we
announced that we are going to
be leaving Preview later on
this year, which we're
very excited about.
Leaving Preview also comes
with a new pricing model.
Let's see.
There's a lot of questions on
our external list. I guess I
could talk about some of
those in person, if
that would be useful.
Whoever yelled it out.
What sort of thing would
you like to hear about?
AUDIENCE: Differences!
GREG DALESANDRE: Differences.
I can't see who it
is who's yelling.
There's just a voice
back there.
So the main differences
in the pricing model
are going to be--
where before there were free
apps, and then apps where you
could turn billing on, and
then you would pay
for what you used.
In the new model, there's
going to be
essentially three types.
There's going to be
free apps, still.
We believe very strongly that
we want to give people free
apps that they can use forever,
so that they can get
started, they can try things.
There are then going
to be paid apps.
So instead of apps where you
have billing turned on, paid
apps are $9 per app, per month,
in addition to the
usage that you use.
But with this $9, you get
an SLA, a 99.95% SLA.
And then there's going to
be premiere accounts.
And premiere accounts
are $500 a month.
You can have as many
apps as you want.
I guess I should have said--
the paid apps, you can
also start paying
for additional usage.
So you can start scaling.
With the premier accounts, it's
$500 per month, but you
get operational support,
as well as all of
your apps can scale.
You don't have to pay an
additional fee per app or
anything like that.
So that's the usage
side of things.
Then one of the big changes is
we're going from CPU hours to
instance hours for billing.
So CPU hours is broken
into two parts now.
Before what we were doing was
charging everyone just based
on the CPU that they
were using now.
For your code that's running,
we're going to be charging
based on the number of instances
that are running,
and how long they're running.
And so essentially, one of the
main reasons we did this-- and
this is something we talked
about a little in the group--
is right now, because we just
used CPU, there's no way to
essentially account for people
who want to use high-memory
applications or high-latency
applications.
And so what happens is we
just don't scale it.
I don't know if any of you
have run into this.
If your latency is two seconds
in your app, what ends up
happening is, it just doesn't
scale in App Engine.
Because essentially, we don't
know how to how to treat
applications like that.
So charging for instances
essentially now opens up this
possibility for everyone who
wants to write applications
and essentially doesn't want to
be constrained by, it only
has to be based on CPU.
They can write high-latency
applications, high
memory-intensive applications,
and essentially pay for their
usage of those.
The other thing that CPU
hours were used for is
for all of the APIs.
We've essentially taken those
APIs and converted what we
were charging before
into operations.
So before, we would charge you
some amount of CPU hour per
XMPP stanza, and now we just
call it a stanza and charge
per stanza.
And again, this was done for
sort of better transparency in
terms of allowing people to
estimate and figure out what
it is they're using, and
how much it will
cost them to use it.
I think I saw a hand go
up at some point.
ALON LEVI: Feel free to
queue up at the mike.
Questions don't have to
be about billing,
but they can be.
AUDIENCE: I just have two kind
of specific questions.
One, with the XMPP
in the stanza.
What about presence
notifications?
GREG DALESANDRE: So I think with
presence notifications--
MAX ROSS: You're asking about
pricing for presence
notifications?
GREG DALESANDRE: Yeah, yeah for
presence notifications.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I suspect
that I know what a stanza
constitutes, but I'd just like
to be clear on presence
notifications that I saw was
relatively recently added.
If users go on- and offline, et
cetera, it [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the app.
So is that additional
charge, or?
BRETT SLATKIN: We're still
figuring out little
details like that.
That's a great example,
because it's a very
high-frequency event that
costs basically nothing,
because there's very
little information.
So I think that these are the
kind of things we're still
trying to work out, before--
GREG DALESANDRE: Our XMPP person
is not here today to
talk in more detail about it.
But I'm in the middle of putting
an FAQ together to
sort of post to the list, and
I'll add that into it.
AUDIENCE: So just one
more small question.
And that is, currently the HR
data store has what is it, a
3X multiple on API CPU usage.
Is that going to be eliminated
as well so that HR and
master/slave are just the same,
as far as cost goes in
the operation?
GREG DALESANDRE: Do you want
to take it [INAUDIBLE]?
MAX ROSS: Yes.
We want everyone to use high
replication data store.
And we've got other things
planned that will encourage
you to move in that direction.
Yes.
Good things.
Yes, carrots.
GREG DALESANDRE: Not beatings.
MAX ROSS: Good things.
Carrots, not sticks.
AUDIENCE: So the growth of
the platform is kind of
phenomenal.
So maybe you could talk about
how you're dealing with the
technical complexities, as well
as the growth in your
team, and how to manage that
sort of complexity?
GREG DALESANDRE: Someone from
SRE maybe want to talk about
some of the growth and
technical complexity?
MATT WILDER: Well, probably the
biggest example of this is
building the high-replication
data store, right?
Something that brings more
liability and more
scalability.
And one of the things that we
learned is, when you have a
service that's really big, a
very small percent of errors
are really painful
so our users.
So this is kind of one of the
first things that I think that
we did to really address the
scalability of the product.
MAX ROSS: Just in terms of
growing the team, one other
thing I would say is, you know,
last year we did one of
these fireside chats.
I don't think any
of our SREs--
you guys weren't up
here with us.
We didn't make a big
announcement that hey, the App
Engine team now has SREs.
But in the lifecycle of a
product within Google, that's
actually a pretty big milestone,
because SREs are in
very short supply.
And so you have to be important
to have these
skilled people helping
support your service.
And that was relatively
new for us around
this time this year.
It's probably been, I don't
know, closer to fifteen or
sixteen months.
AUDIENCE: SRE means what?
MAX ROSS: Site reliability
engineers.
So yeah, thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL HANDLER: Yeah.
So there's been SRE engagement
with App Engine
since January of 2010.
And I'm giving a talk on it at
3 o'clock over in the other
hallway, Life in Production.
And you know, I'm not going
to just reveal everything.
I'll just take over the
rest of this and give
the talk right now.
Just get it done.
Dry run.
But It's fantastic.
Google is a moving environment
in same way that app engine
scaling is a moving
environment.
So we're getting tremendous
growth.
People are using the platform
in ways that we never
anticipated.
And we're thrilled about that,
but at the same time, Google's
not standing still saying, well,
this is what we offer.
Google is growing.
We've got other products
coming online.
Infrastructure changes,
disruptions that are caused by
changes in the infrastructure,
surprises that come to us.
And this is all what I end up
talking about, and the high
replication data store is based
very explicitly on what
we learned, and I talk very
explicitly about some of the
things that happened to us,
some of the things that we
know could happen to us, some
of the things that we're
afraid could happen to us, and
that HR data store handles way
better than the master/slave
data store ever could.
So come see my talk.
GREG DALESANDRE: The other thing
I just wanted to add is,
we're also seeing a wider
variety of customer types.
Right?
You know, it's kind of like
when you're just getting
started and people are just sort
of trying something out
that's new, there's a certain
sort of type of developer who
will kind of give it a shot.
Now we're seeing a very wide
range of people to--
enterprises you wouldn't expect
who are looking into
using it, as well as one person
startups who are our
doing it on the weekend.
And so I think it's been
interesting trying to support
and handle such a wide
variety of customers.
AUDIENCE: I had a more technical
question, and that
was, is there is a good way to
sink the memcache across
different instances?
BRETT SLATKIN: I mean, every
instance should have the same
view of memcache?
AUDIENCE: Right.
BRETT SLATKIN: So could
you clarify?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
One application that I've
got is collaborative
story-writing, and we'll have
50 or 100 people come in and
they're all exchanging messages,
and stuff like that.
But I've got a thing that's
checking to see if their
browser needs to refresh
based on what it's
giving for the memcache.
And I found the when it was 20
new instances, it didn't have
that same information.
They had to--
BRETT SLATKIN: Yeah, I mean,
memcache is supposed to be a
consistent view shared
by all instances.
Sometimes you get evicted, and
then you lose the information
so it can go away.
But I think that you should
definitely check out the new
backend feature that they
launched yesterday, which kind
of lets you write your own
stateful memory resident
backend that has a
consistent view.
And maybe that'd be a
better fit for what
you're trying to do.
But if you could stop by our
office hours and kind of give
us some more detail, I think
that would be really helpful.
Because that's not how
it should work.
It should be there.
That's the point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
the integration between Google
Apps and Google App Engine, and
what's there now and what
do you see as far as being able
to access corporate data
stored in docs that's related
to Google Apps?
PETER MAGNUSSON: We plan
to improve that.
Great question.
ERIC MORRIS: Echo the great
question from the sales side
of the house, as well.
We need a better answer.
We're actively working to
make better and tighter
integrations between those,
because it's something that
people ask us about
all the time.
AUDIENCE: We use your
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to interact with other services
outside of app engine.
Unfortunately, we work with
Apple for its notifications,
and that has to connect on
a non-HTTP protocol.
Is there any plan to make
something which is
non-HTTP-based, URL patch or is
this something that doesn't
work with Google infrastructure,
or
something like that?
SEAN LYNCH: One of the things
that we're currently working
on is adding support
for sockets.
So you will be able to reach out
on non-HTTP connections.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Any timeline on that?
Because we're actually
[INAUDIBLE]
notification.
SEAN LYNCH: No timeline
at the moment.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: There is a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
initiative back in India, which
is probably the world's
largest private cloud
that we're building.
And currently, they are
planning to use a
[? nautical ?]
database, which is based on
the Bigtable whitepaper
because App Engine is not open
source, and you don't have
support for private clouds.
Is there any initiative from
that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
other option for such kind
of large private cloud
initiative?
SEAN LYNCH: So the whole
discussion of private cloud
and things like that--
first options, there are
actually two separate open
source implementations of the
App Engine API, a Tycoon AE
and AppScale.
And they're using projects like
Cassandra to sort of back
the API equivalent of a
data store in terms of
functionality.
From our perspective, when we're
talking about things
like HRD, there's just
not a way that we
can bottle that up.
The fact that we have Mike and
Matt working behind the scenes
to do sort of failovers between
multiple data centers
at once isn't sort of something
that we can put in a
box and let you throw
on a rack.
And that's sort of the
fundamental difference when
people talk about private clouds
as sort of an option.
You don't have these guys, you
don't have this team actually
maintaining the data store
or the database, whatever
technology you choose.
So for private clouds, there
are a lot of really
interesting open source projects
in the no-sequel
space that provide similar or
complimentary functionality,
but you can't get a lot of the
things that the public cloud
gives you, especially when you
look at examples like HRD,
behind your firewall.
Unless you hire these
guys and--
GREG DALESANDRE: Don't
hire these guys.
That's not an option.
AUDIENCE: Google as a company
doesn't have any plans to do
open source or create
services?
Are other companies creating
service of
their own at open source?
GREG DALESANDRE: Well, as Sean
mentioned, our APIs are open
sourced, and there are two
external, third party
companies that are building App
Engine compatible servers.
SEAN LYNCH: Yeah.
I mean, at Google, our
proficiency is the cloud.
That's what we know.
And we do very, very
well at that.
And so that's where we
will continue to
do very, very well.
AUDIENCE: So one of the great
things about App Engine is,
there's no [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
it.
You don't have to pay.
Will the change to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the billing, change that?
If I have more instances, am
I been billed for that?
GREG DALESANDRE: So one of
the things, again, on the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
we talked about a lot--
it's still designed to be pay
as you go, in terms of, if
there are instances serving
traffic, you're paying for
those instances that are
serving traffic.
One of the things that we have--
and there was a talk
about this yesterday--
we have a scheduler which
essentially decides how many
instances should be running
based on the amount of traffic
that you have coming in.
And that's what essentially
spins up new instances when
the traffic demands it, and
takes down instances when
traffic is no longer needed.
We're in the process of
essentially improving that
scheduler or, to be more
precise, making that scheduler
fit with the instance model.
And so that essentially is
going to choose how many
instances you have running.
But the point is, for instance,
if you have no
traffic at all, you shouldn't be
paying for instances unless
you've made a decision that
you want to have instances
running just in case new
traffic comes along.
But again, that would be sort of
a decision you'd make of, I
want to leave instances
up, just in case new
traffic comes up.
Does that answer the question?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Should we expect
to see tighter BigQuery
integration?
GREG DALESANDRE: Oh, BigQuery.
Anyone on stage who
can talk to this?
So I think the short answer is,
it's definitely an area
where we're looking at.
You probably saw the Google
Storage announcement
yesterday, as well.
And all of these parts, we
definitely want to and are
working on playing more
closely with.
As I'm sure you're used to
hearing this answer, we can't
give timelines as to when
they're going to be done.
But it's certainly absolutely on
our roadmap of things that
we're looking at doing, is
integrating with some of the
other sort of cloud services
from Google.
ALON LEVI: Yeah.
Another way to answer that
is that we want all the
integrations.
Right?
We think all this stuff
is really cool.
We'd like to have it
all integrated.
It's just a matter of
prioritizing everything, again.
Stability improvement and
other things like that.
So yeah, we definitely
want it to happen.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And that's really the gist
of the question.
It's priority for me, but--
GREG DALESANDRE: SSL is
a higher priority on
our list right now.
WESLEY CHUN: The ability to have
an App Engine application
as an input source to analysis
is certainly something that
we're looking at as a use
case for the platform.
BRETT SLATKIN: I was just going
to add that I think also
a lot of this fall under the
OAuth2 kind of heading.
So we're starting to deploy
OAuth2 for services, which
makes these integrations
a lot easier.
The docs integrations that
someone else asked about
earlier using the Google Apps
or Google Docs APIs, is hard
now for a variety of reasons.
One of them is Auth.
So authorization authentication
is hard, and
OAuth 2 simplifies that a lot.
So as we move more and more of
our services to use OAuth2,
then stuff like integrating App
Engine with BigQuery or
App Engine with Google
Apps will get easier.
So the other Auth teams at
Google have been laying the
foundation to let us simplify
the problem.
So I think that's kind of a
bigger picture answer, too.
GREG DALESANDRE: Right.
And I think that'll help.
But that being said, we also
want to make sure that it's
easy to run App Engine
with non-Google--
you know, I think we try in
general not to do anything too
crazy custom just to have a
single point of integration.
I think we do, in general, as
much as possible, try to make
the integrations sort
of generalized.
And so for instance OAuth 2
is great example of that.
OAuth 2 is something that parts
of Google are moving to,
and so it'll work well together,
but it's also
something that third parties
outside of Google can use
OAuth2 and then we'll work
well with them, too.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, gentlemen.
GREG DALESANDRE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you very much
for App Engine.
It's a really fun product
form to develop with.
My question is, in the last two
days, we've seen a little
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that it's going to make the
product form way bigger and
maybe less simple.
And one thing that I've noticed
with App Engine is,
there's like a very good
best practice.
But if you don't follow it
because you don't know it or
whatever, and then you push the
production, migrating data
or anything kind
of complicated.
So my question is, what
resources or guidelines or
ideas can you give us so we can
keep up to date with the
best practice as a whole
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Just the mailing list?
GREG DALESANDRE: I can answer,
unless somebody else wants to.
WESLEY CHUN: The mailing
list is good.
Our blog is good.
A number of our Dev Advocates
and DevRel people
also blog, as well.
I think our documentation
is excellent.
So the documentation is fairly
sparse, but it's enough
information to get
you started.
So part of the members of the
developer relations team, our
job is to take the stuff and
build more realistic examples
that you would use.
So keep an eye out for a blog
post, as well as articles
under the documentation that
give you more of that.
And we're also working
on a best
practices article, as well.
MIKE AIZATSKY: We also have been
talking for years about
having some kind of
community-driven documentation
project like wiki.
Unfortunately, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is like SSL stuff and
other things.
So if you guys write App Engine
app which is a wiki,
we'll be happy to contribute,
certainly.
If someone tells me, hey, we
need two lines about best
practices to use memcashe,
I would just
go and write something.
So just collaborate
together guys.
Give us a place to contribute
that kind of best practices.
TOM EDWARD HAZEN:
And two things.
First is that we're planning
some specific best practices
documents, one related
to security.
I'd like to take some of the
stuff that Guido and Justin
talked about in their scaling
talk yesterday and create a
document about best practices
in regard to scaling.
Second is that if anybody wants
to actively contribute
to App Engine documentation,
we're
looking for another writer.
So if you'd like to write some
best practices documentation,
please see me after the talk.
ALON LEVI: I should also add
that as you see places where
it's a little murkier, it's
not clear what the best
practice is, please come on the
forums and ask questions
for clarification and things
like that, you know?
There's a lot more of you than
there are of us, and so when
you point out something that
we can take a look at and
provide an answer to,
it's pretty helpful.
GREG DALESANDRE: And we do
monitor the forums, and
respond when other people aren't
responding or when it's
important for Google
to respond.
But yeah, I would say the two
main places to look are our
blog, which is quite active,
as well as the forms.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: What sorts of services
are you looking to
provide in the $500 a month
kind of enterprise tier?
And as an agency, we're kind
of continually running up
against the like ten apps
per user count.
Is that the sort of thing that
would go away once the
pricing's in place?
GREG DALESANDRE: Yeah.
So for the premier accounts that
are $500 per month, one
of the main things that you'll
get is operational support,
which a lot of our customers
have been asking us for, so
that they know that they
can contact somebody.
So asking a question on the list
will almost always get
you a response, but a lot of
times you want essentially a
guaranteed response on it, not
sort of waiting when somebody
gets to it, essentially.
But the other thing it does give
you is as many apps as
you want, all of which
can scale.
So if you're trying to run
hundreds of apps, it's
probably a good way
for you to go.
Those are the two sort of main
aspects that you get with it.
There are things that, over
time, we might start adding
in, that are kind of much
more of the sort of like
enterprise-y type features.
But for the most part, that's
what it is right now.
Does that make sense?
Great.
No more questions?
Come on.
There's got to be
more questions.
ALON LEVI: Come on, guys.
We're not even halfway done.
AUDIENCE: SSL?
GREG DALESANDRE: SSL?
So what do you mean by--
I'm just kidding.
SSL is a very high
priority for us.
We don't have a date that
we can announce it--
PETER MCKENZIE: I can
say something.
So I'm responsible for SSL.
GREG DALESANDRE: I was just
trying to protect him!
That's all.
PETER MCKENZIE: We are actively
working on it and
making good progress.
We can't give a date, but it's
certainly high priority.
To be honest, we would have
liked to have launched it by
now, but it's certainly foremost
in my thoughts, and
in the thoughts of several
others of my team.
BRETT SLATKIN: Two things
that would speed it up.
Get everyone to install
an S&I browser.
So upgrade everyone to IE9
or Chrome or whatever.
If you do that, that'd
be cool.
Other thing is, everyone
move to IPV6.
That would also help us
get the shift sooner.
So if you could help us out
there, that'd be great.
We're working on our side.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to do
the first with [INAUDIBLE]?
BRETT SLATKIN: No.
You get this warning prompt that
says you're going to die.
I mean, it doesn't work, yeah.
So that's a problem.
If you don't have a browser
that's compatible to SNI, then
you can't use it.
It looks like you're
being phished or
hacked or stolen from.
AUDIENCE: Triple w dot domain,
and then do a little browser
test, and direct
to [INAUDIBLE]?
BRETT SLATKIN: You can't even
test. It just freaks out.
When you try to get somebody
to go to a site, it just
rejects it outright.
So that's the issue.
You can't even test for it.
MICHAEL HANDLER: I'd just like
to say operationally that I'm
thrilled that all the mistakes
we made with HTTP, we managed
to make again with HTTPS as a
community, that it's great,
because it means full
employment for me.
So when we're designing
protocols, let's keep it up,
make the same mistakes over and
over again, and I can't
wait to have a funeral for all
of the hacks that we need
system Y to deal with this.
GREG DALESANDRE: There are
a lot more questions now!
AUDIENCE: So you guys just
announced support for Go.
What other languages would you
like to see App Engine run on?
GREG DALESANDRE: What would
we like to see, or--
MAX ROSS: What would
you like to see?
GREG DALESANDRE:
We don't really
matter in this equation.
So, well, you got
what you wanted.
No.
AUDIENCE: I want Python 3!
GREG DALESANDRE: Right, OK.
So definitely Python 3.
One or two people might
have asked for PHP.
I don't know if we've,
have we heard?
Just kidding.
Lots of people ask for
PHP all the time.
And that's certainly another
language we know people are
asking for.
I think people have talked
about like Node.js,
that sort of thing.
You know, we announced the
experimental Go run time,
which we have Andrew here from
the Go team who's going to
answer questions about that,
if people are interested in
asking about that.
We don't have any other
run times we can
announce at this point.
AUDIENCE: Would you support
languages that weren't
internally used at Google?
GREG DALESANDRE: Would we?
Sure.
I mean, there's nothing to
stop us from doing that.
Again, it's a matter of
prioritization, integrations,
and all these other things.
MICKEY KATARIA: And just
a quick comment.
For those of you who have been
paying attention to our public
roadmap, Python 2.7's
on there.
We are working on
support for 2.7.
PETER MAGNUSSON: Yeah.
So I wanted to go to respond to
the notion of if it's got
to do with internal languages.
It's not that there's a policy
that no, we're not going to
support other languages.
It's that we have a Go team
internally, and we do Go work
internally.
I'm hoping that we'll be able
to figure out ways to allow
external communities to
participate in adding more
languages and so forth.
We'll see what happens
down the road.
I do want to emphasize, though,
that with Go, we're
adding something that's
fundamentally different than
we would have with the other
language options, which is
that that's a generally
compiled, low-level language
that we'll be able to
run in App Engine.
So that will be very useful
for services and so forth.
ANDREW DURAND: I was just
going to say that it was
actually at the Go team's kind
of impetus that we started
this project.
And we didn't kind of detract
resources from the App Engine
team proper and pull their
engineers onto it.
It was actually, we got more
people on the Go team, and
expanded our efforts to make
this happen with the help of
the App Engine team.
So none of the bugs on the
issue tracker that you're
feverishly waiting to
be fixed didn't get
fixed because of Go.
So don't hold that against us.
BRETT SLATKIN: And to add to
that, Go as a language has an
unsafe package.
PHP does not have an
I think that's just dot
PHP is the unsafe
package for PHP, right?
So I think part of this is about
isolation, security.
When people say PHP, they
don't mean the language.
They mean the environment.
They mean it running
in Apache.
They mean a very specific set
of C extensions that are
community-driven.
So I think that if you try to
understand how easy is it for
a language to be brought into
App Engine, you need to think
about the full picture of
what it means, right?
A language is not
just a language.
You've been able to run PHP as
just a pure language on App
Engine through [? Quirkus ?],
through the Java run time,
for a very long time.
But that's not what people want,
and that's not what they
consider PHP.
So that's another thing to
remember, is that when people
ask for language, they're
asking for how
they program now.
MIKE AIZATSKY: And the other
thing to keep in mind is that
we'd like to have all languages,
but I'm part of run
times and API teams, as we call
it, but the whole process
does not care.
So just let me give
you a picture now.
When you want to implement an
API, you have to implement
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You have to implement
API in type.
API in Java.
You have to implement API in
Python developer server, and
you have to implement API in
Java developer server.
Now the Go comes in.
So you now have to implement
it Go API.
Fortunately they use Python
developer server.
But every extra language adds
a tremendous maintenance
complexity for us.
And the whole process
does not scale.
If you threw in five languages
more, we would be like 100% of
the time just catching up the
languages with each other.
So we'll have to start
somewhere.
But we would definitely like
to see more languages.
ANDREW DURAND: And
just one to add.
Late last year, we added a page
to the Go website which
allows you to run
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Go code in a sandbox environment
on Google servers.
And so we have the Go expertise
on the Go team to
make that happen, and we already
demonstrated that we
could do that.
And so taking that sandbox and
showing that to the App Engine
team, saying, hey, we've already
done this, it was much
easier for them to take us on
board than to look at a
totally unfamiliar language,
which we don't have domain
expertise in and try
and approach
that colossal problem.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to support sharing a data
store between apps?
MAX ROSS: Yes.
We talk about that
all the time.
I think I've probably even
answered that same question up
here in years past. But it's
actually getting closer to
becoming a reality.
There's some infrastructure
improvements that are going to
make that a lot easier for us.
It's somewhat similar to what
Brett was talking about with
OAuth, although the details
are different.
But there are pieces that make
it hard today that are going
to become easier very soon.
You may have seen--
well, actually, I don't want
to get too much into the
details of it.
But the types of things that
we have in mind are the
ability to use the same data
store service API that you're
used to in whatever language
that you program against. But
have some way to have those
calls just transparently
redirected someplace else.
And we've got to get the
plumbing right, and we've got
to make sure that we are
connecting things in a safe
way, we've got to get
the apples right.
I think we understand it pretty
well, but we need a
couple of infrastructure pieces
in place, and then we
need to prioritize
it appropriately.
But it's closer this year
than it was last year.
And we do have some very
concrete ideas about how this
might work.
That's the best I
can tell you.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
question about
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
How will the certificate
management work?
Will it be bring your own
certificate, or does Google
have a CA that will issue--
PETER MCKENZIE: It will be bring
your own certificate.
You'll be able to upload your
certificate, and we'll serve
that for you.
GREG DALESANDRE: That's
what I like to see.
More questions.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
What are you doing with regard
to roles for administration?
I noticed recently there were
little enhancements there.
Can you talk about what you
might be doing going forward,
and then also, just any
discussion you can give us
around some of the experimental
sequel server
stuff that's out there?
GREG DALESANDRE: So for role--
Guido, you want to
talk to it, or?
GUIDO VON ROSSUM: We don't have
any specific plans to
sort of add more roles
or more probations.
But the sort of infrastructure
we have for roles certainly
would support more roles.
So if we get sufficient feedback
saying, well, there's
a particular category of
administrator in our system
for which we would like to have
a role that can do this
but not that, and
yet sort of--
then we can certainly relatively
easily add that to
the system.
So write up exactly what kind of
role you would like to have
added, and we'll look at it.
GREG DALESANDRE:
And in response
to the sequel question--
so sequel is actually currently
in trusted tester.
It has been for a
little while.
This answer is going to
sound similar to SSL.
We're working hard on it.
We know it's really important.
Although sequel actually
is in trusted tester.
So if you're interested in
trying it out and seeing what
it's like, you can certainly
join our
trusted tester program.
We know how critical it is, and
it's a high priority to
get it out there, but
things take time.
AUDIENCE: This is probably
more of an office hours
question, but since you're
running out of questions.
It's a dumb debugging
question.
I've got a Python App Engine app
that's been running fine.
It's not production yet, so I'm
not worried about the bug.
But what's happening is I'm
getting very intermittent--
it uses OpenID OpenAuth to
connect up to fusion tables.
And very intermittently, I'm
getting 403 Forbidden errors
when I try to connect
to the app.
It runs fine for days, and
then all of a sudden, I'm
getting 403 Forbiddens
for a while.
And it'll be on one browser
but not another browser.
It's not cookies.
You don't have to look
at all that stuff.
Take a brand new browser, and
if VM has never seen the app
before, it'll get it, or not.
It's just pretty intermittent.
Anything jump out at anybody,
or I'll do some more
troubleshooting on my own.
No?
[INAUDIBLE]
the team!
AUDIENCE: It's hard to
debug when you don't
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
GREG DALESANDRE: Debugging
on stage, huh?
MICKEY KATARIA: One possibility,
and I don't know
off the top of my head for
fusion tables, is that a lot
of the APIs do sort of IP-based
limiting or some kind
of limiting which
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
maybe occasionally you're
running into some of these.
So that's one area to look at.
AUDIENCE: Possibly.
Yeah, I can't even connect to
my app, is what's happening.
But I'll do some more
troubleshooting.
GREG DALESANDRE: Or you can
come by office hours.
AUDIENCE: Again, this question
is about the asynchronous API
that recently came up for
Data Store that's
currently in Java.
I want to understand whether
it's there on Python already.
And a follow-up question
to whether there is any
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in using async API.
Is it ready to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
where sync merely a waiting
call, or is satellite
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you create keys with
new, fresh entities?
Two different [INAUDIBLE].
ALFRED FULLER: So the async
API for Python is out.
Was that 150?
GREG DALESANDRE: 150, yeah.
ALFRED FULLER: Yeah.
It was out in 150.
It's in every level.
So it's in ext.db, and
datastore.py, and even lower.
So I recommend you
check it out.
And synchronous calls
call the async calls
and then call block.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So no worry.
ALFRED FULLER: Yeah.
You should totally use it.
It's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Any word on expanding
the one megabyte
limit for entities?
MAX ROSS: You know, we've got
some ideas about how maybe we
could split it up.
But we have some internal limits
on transaction ties
that we would need to clear
out first. And those are
limits that are not just in our
layer, but in layers that
go further down the stack.
So we would love to get rid of
that one, but we've got our
work cut out for us to do it.
BRETT SLATKIN: I'd just add
that Mike has deployed the
file API that just came out.
It's a little experimental,
but it's deployed in the
Mapper framework,
[? mapperdev.appspot.com. ?]
And it solved this
problem for me.
I've been doing a bunch of
things with it where I have to
write, you know, 100 megs of
random data, and then index it
based on other properties.
So that's what I've
been doing.
So the size of my entity only
really needs the blob key,
blob reference property, and
then a bunch of other stuff.
And that scales out
as big as I want.
Because of relation indexes, I
can go as large as I possibly
could imagine.
So I think that it requires
you to kind of move things
around a little bit, but I
don't find this to be a
problem anymore because
of the file API.
So that's still experimental,
but I encourage you to try
that and to use that instead.
If you need your indexes to be
larger than 1 meg, you can add
multiple trial entities
to do those queries.
That works really well.
If you need even more data to
be indexed, maybe the full
text search thing that they
were talking about earlier
today is a better fit.
I don't know beyond that.
But that's how I've been working
around this, and I've
had success with it.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to allow copying an app in
production, including production
data, for like
testing purposes?
MIKE AIZATSKY: If you deploy
at least one Python
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
which might be absolutely empty,
then you're going to
have the data store
admin pages.
And there is two functions
and they're just
through admin right now.
The first one is to delete
data and the other
one is to copy data.
So you could set up another
app, open remote API.
There are like some instructions
how to do that.
But you can actually
pick these entities
and copy them over.
And it will start the Mapper
job, and it will copy the data
to the other app.
And it can override data, so you
can actually catch up on
changes, whatever.
GREG DALESANDRE: Just as
a side note on that.
We often get questions about
sort of what's kind of the
intended deployment process
for App Engine, right?
If you want to have like a dev
app, a test app, and a
production app, something
like that.
And this is something that we've
been talking about sort
of putting more effort into
around trying to, again,
prioritize against all
the other stuff, too.
But just because, I think this
question comes up a lot,
because I imagine that's
what you were
trying to get at, right?
You want to sort of have a clone
of these things, and if
you use live versions, then
it's all in the same data
store, and so you want
multiple apps.
And so we'll look into sort of
figuring out what the right
way to do that is, and then sort
of making that easier and
making kind of the tools.
We might try to do a best
practices before that, just so
that people are sort
of heading on
down the right path.
MATT WILDER: So in terms of
copying data from one
application to another, this
is the primary way we're
working on having applications
migrate to high replication.
Because we have to copy your
data from the master/slave
data store to the high
replication data store.
And so we're hard at
work building out
the tools to do that.
It's very likely that those new
tools, will be able to use
to do other sorts of migrations,
as well.
GREG DALESANDRE: Peter, did
you have something?
PETER MCKENZIE: Well,
I'm not sure I'm
answering the same question.
But in terms of testing and
different app versions, name
spaces could also play into
that, and how you manage your
roll-out process.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious to know
about data source import and
export tools that you can pull
out in your roadmap.
Data tools, import and
export tools, how
that's coming along?
BRETT SLATKIN: Well, we have the
bulk loader, and there's
an experimental version.
I think it's in SVN?
Yeah, it is.
So there's a newer
version of it.
I think it's the
old prototype.
It's experimental.
It's in the bulk loader
SVN repository.
But effectively, it does all
of the stuff on the server
side, exports to using the file
APIs to some giant blob.
You download the whole blob, and
then you can reupload it,
and then import from
that blob again.
So those kind of tools are
really good for backups, or
for saving and restore, or for
copying between apps, or for
saving golden data that
you then upload
for staging and testing.
So we've made progress
in that direction.
The tools are not ready
for primetime.
I think this fits in also with
the tools we're using for high
replication data store.
So a lot of effort in that
direction, and I think all
these tools will kind of
converge really soon.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if you see
adding official support to
any number of open source
projects, or if that actually
enables you to use resources for
other things that aren't
covered by existing open
source projects.
Basically, how do open source
projects fit into the grand
scheme of things?
BRETT SLATKIN: I feel like
you're talking to me.
Well, we have a bunch of places
where we talk about
open source projects.
Especially like Objectify and
some other kind of specialized
ORMs that are really--
or like in Japan, there's
something called flim3.
That's the biggest
thing for writing
web apps on App Engine.
So these are not officially
supported.
But the community has built
tools that are, for certain
styles of programming, much
better than the tools that
we've built, depending on the
kind of developer you are.
Like if you're a spring guy,
there's some tool that's
better for spring guys.
So I think maybe we should
officially support these.
But we have the list of tools,
will it work on App Engine,
and stuff like that.
And we try to maintain
those kind of
things the best we can.
But maybe a rubber stamp would
be useful to you, like
recommended or something
like that?
AUDIENCE: Where integration
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
a large part--
sorry.
Where integration of projects
that still some missing,
functionality gap that maybe is
not general enough to meet
everyone's needs.
Things like sessions or RPC.
GREG DALESANDRE: So the other
thing I was going to say as
well is that it's hard
to say what kind of
official support means.
Although I think we want to
encourage the open source
community as much as possible.
We talked earlier about the
other open source, some
limitations of App
Engine itself.
And I think we like that,
we want to encourage it.
It takes some amount of time
on our side when we open
source APIs and those sort of
things, for instance, and so
it's, of course,
all a balance.
But over the course of the year,
I think, we'll start to
figure out if there's more
things we can do to sort of
encourage some of
these projects.
MIKE AIZATSKY: The one thing
which I wanted to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
by our 20% project is, I wanted
to create, and I still
want to create an open source
community to fulfill those
smaller parts which do not
have their own project.
And I call this operation
afterburner, because
afterburner makes
you run faster.
And I always tend to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
produce [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Google [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
but I want to announce
it really soon.
But it's not going to
be the place for us.
It's not going to be like
official support.
We just want to have one single
space for people.
If you've got some use
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to it, you know there is a place
to go to look at, or a
place to contribute it to.
So I want to announce
it maybe in a month,
something like that.
AUDIENCE: Hey, if I want to
use my new Chromebook for
development of an app engine
in the cloud, do I have any
options for that?
BRETT SLATKIN: I think
it's control T.
It'll go to the shell, and
then you can just--
no.
[LAUGHTER]
GUIDO VON ROSSUM: There
will be something.
It's not ready.
SEAN LYNCH: There's a couple of
third party ones available
right now, too.
I think Cloud9 just launched
sort of an IDE, and they do
deployment into App Engine.
I think if you look around,
there's actually a couple of
different options that are
sort of cloud-based or
web-based development
environments that we'll sort
of hook into App Engine.
AUDIENCE: The Python SDK is 100%
open source, but is there
any thought of opening the
Java SDK in the same way?
MAX ROSS: Yes.
I believe with 150, there's a
little bit of it that's open
source, and I think you can
expect to see a lot more in
the next release.
So, yeah.
We want all of it open source,
and it's taken us a little
while to get our
ducks in a row.
But just that little bit of open
source in 150, that means
all of the hard work has been
done, and now we've got some
busy work to do to get
the rest of it out
there, but it's coming.
SEAN LYNCH: One plug is that
the Go run time is already
open sourced.
So they beat the Java guys.
ANDREW DURAND: We are an open
source project, so we've got
an unfair advantage.
AUDIENCE: There was quite a
huge outage this March.
Who broke Python run time, and
what did you do to make sure
that this won't happen again?
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL HANDLER: There's always
surprises coming.
And you should come
to my talk.
And things break in ways that
we didn't think that we ever
had to monitor.
And the first thing that we do
the minute something happens
that we don't expect, after
we fix it, is we say, OK.
How can we detect how that
would happen again?
How can we detect those
classes of problems
beforehand, before it
hits production?
How can we detect that in devel,
in QA, in our early
internal instance, so that we
find that beforehand and go,
wait, stop.
We broke that.
And let's not make that
happen to production.
And we have really good
coverage, but reality is
always ready to surprise you.
So that's unfortunately as much
as I can say about that
particular incident.
SEAN LYNCH: There is also
a public postmortem.
I'm assuming it was like
the March 8--?
So there's a public postmortem
that we posted as well.
So I don't know if you got
a chance to see that.
MAX ROSS: It took us a little
bit longer than usual to get
that one out there.
But we take these public
postmortems really seriously.
We're not trying to blow smoke
in anybody's eyes.
If you think that we are not
being transparent enough, we
want to know.
Because we want to be as
transparent as we possibly can
with you about what went wrong
and we're doing to prevent it
from happening again.
AUDIENCE: Is there any specific
reason why the
planned outages, or is that like
5 PM in the area most of
your developers would live?
That's sort of in the middle of
our work day, and sort of
affects our revenue at
a very serious peak
time for our users.
GREG DALESANDRE: That sounds
like someone not running HR.
MATT WILDER: I was going
to say two things.
One is, you don't have
to worry about
these if you use HR.
Two is that the procedure
involved in performing that
maintenance--
we talked about this a little
bit in our HR [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
talk--
requires an engineer to do a
whole bunch of very specific
steps, and we don't want to be
up at five in the morning.
Also, there are things that can
go wrong, so we want more
than one person around when
those things happen.
GREG DALESANDRE: We also are,
you know, people are using App
Engine across the world.
And so it's always going to be
inconvenient for someone.
MATT WILDER: It's always
5 PM somewhere, right?
ALFRED FULLER: Also, the data
store, which is what causes
these planned maintenances, for
the most part, to take an
hour, as we talked to this
morning, uses common
infrastructure.
And so if something goes wrong,
we want those teams to
be available and around to make
sure that you experience
as little down time as possible
in those rare
situations.
So one of the reasons why we do
that is because it doesn't
just involve us.
It involves a lot of other
teams. And in those times,
they're more available than they
would be if we did it at
midnight, or some other time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRETT SLATKIN: I'm just
going to plug the
HR data store again.
I have two apps that are very
dear to me that I run.
One is on master/slave, and one
is on the HR data store.
I launched something on the HR
data store an hour before the
maintenance this last week.
I didn't even know.
I had no idea.
And I'm like pushing code
and doing everything.
So I think that I've just
forgotten about it.
Meanwhile, I'm getting paged on
my phone because my other
app was having some issues.
So I think that, just in my own
experience, it's totally
changed my frame of mind to
have the HR data store.
I've had to work around the ways
that it's different, but
really, see if you
can move to it.
It's not a gimmick.
It's really serious,
what it gives you.
AUDIENCE: I have a follow
up question, but I'll
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: This is the additional
question on OpenID
implementation on App Engine.
You know the single sign on
for social networks like
Facebook and Twitter is
very small, is you
really look at it.
But the OpenID implementation
for Google,
it's a little shaky.
Probably because Google accounts
and the Google app
are two different log ins,
and if you have to do
a single sign on--
BRETT SLATKIN: So Twitter is
everybody but OAuth, and
Facebook is OpenID.
I'm saying, they're
not, right?
So could be more specific
about what the--
AUDIENCE: For example, if you
have a Like button, you know,
once you have logged in into
Facebook, you don't have to
really worry about when you go
to a different site, click on
Like if you want to
be logged in.
But in Google, you don't
have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in Gmail or in, let's say,
you're in a domain like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
you don't know which one
you are in, right?
So.
BRETT SLATKIN: So this
is by design.
This is because if it weren't
like that, if there were paths
of login everywhere, then people
could drive by, steal
your information.
So they could put a widget in
the bottom of a page, you go
to the page, and then you send
a request off to their site,
you're automatically logged in,
and now they know who you
are, or your ID, et
cetera, et cetera.
It works great for Facebook and
for a lot of single sign
on things, because they're
the center of it, so
they are OK with that.
Publishers pull that too.
But if you apply that to every
App Engine app, and there's
200,000 of them, then you've
got a security problem.
And so I think that we're trying
to strike the right
balance there.
If you can think of some good
ideas of how to work around
that, we'd love to hear them.
But that's, I think, the
best balance we've
been able to find.
SEAN LYNCH: Specifically on
the OpenID implementation,
we've got some--
I don't think they made it to
IO, but some changes, or some
new features coming along that
way that should also smooth
out some of the integration
bits.
So that might help you address
your problem, as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you're deciding how to
price App Engine, I'm curious,
going forward, how do
you view the typical
customer of app engine?
Given that there's an enormous
variance of price sensitivity
between the enterprising folks
that would be otherwise
spending millions of dollars on
Oracle and then the other
people that are writing the
Facebook fad of the week app.
GREG DALESANDRE: So we're
relatively transparent about
that by our sort of three
different usage types of free
apps, paid apps, and
premiere accounts.
Where we really sort of thought
about it from the
perspective of free apps are
designed to allow people to
try out App Engine, if they want
to try out App Engine, or
if they want to use App Engine
for a long period of time
without paying anything.
It's designed to do that.
But you know, you get
to a point where--
you know, you're all trying to
run businesses, and we're
trying to run a business
as well, right?
And so the paid app is then, for
kind of the profile of it,
we're sort of small people--
not small people, but
small businesses.
Like a couple people who were
looking to run their apps, but
don't necessarily need
operational support, it's OK
for them to go to the
list. $9 a month.
I think somebody on the list
said that it was two cups of
coffee a month.
Actually, these days, depending
where you go, it's
one cup of coffee a month.
But the goal was, it's important
that there's a
monthly fee in there to pay
for the SLA, and also to
essentially establish
a contract with us.
It's very difficult to have an
SLA, and a lot of them-- we
got the feedback from customers
before where they
really, really wanted to just
have a relationship with us,
where they wanted to make sure
that we felt accountable to
them, but their usage wasn't
that large, even though they
felt like what they were doing
was important to them.
And so it's kind of hard, when
you're getting something for
free, to come into Google and
be like, I can't believe it
went down, this thing that
you're letting me do for free.
So the paid apps are really for
small businesses, and then
the premier accounts are for
enterprises, large businesses,
or even like consulting
organizations, those kind of
people, who are using a lot
of apps to do a lot
of different things.
AUDIENCE: I guess what I'm
wondering is about the part of
the ecosystem that has very high
traffic apps with very,
very small margins.
PETER MAGNUSSON: So just
to be clear, the price
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that we're doing now is targeted
at the self-selected
group of current App
Engine users.
So it was pretty much entirely
driven off of analysis of
current usage, current apps.
And we did extensive--
you know, we're a
metric-oriented company.
We did extensive slicing and
dicing of all those numbers,
and looked at how this
impacted different
kinds of use cases.
And we targeted so that for
the vast, vast majority, a
very high percentage of current
users, would look at
the price as being, OK, well,
this is still a really good
deal, and it's cheaper
than any alternative.
There's going to be pathological
cases where
you've basically been riding on
the fact that we've had a
subsidized service, and
that you might have
to look at it again.
I've talked to some developers
that have said, well, OK, we
just needed to go in and
rearchitect a little bit, and
optimize a little bit, and guess
what, then the usage
numbers went down by a
certain percentage.
But it should be a very small
percentage who are
impacted in that way.
Conversely, for most apps that
are paying money, the
consequence is going to
be that you're going
to be paying more.
I mean, there's no ifs
or buts about that.
But that is also by intention,
because we want this to be a
really successful commercial
product for Google so we can
build on it.
And it also should
not be compared
with unmanaged services.
I've seen some online
discussions about, you know,
it's cheaper to do
x over here.
When you do the aggregate
comparison, you should look at
the aggregate of your whole
service, and you should
consider the fact that on App
Engine, you're getting a fully
managed service.
So we're happy to look at any
particular benchmarks.
We had internal, a dozen or so
different models for different
use cases, where we wanted to be
competitive on all of them.
So I think at the end of the
day, the community is going to
still find it's a really,
really good deal.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GREG DALESANDRE: So I think
we're almost out of time.
So maybe one last question?
AUDIENCE: I've just got
a really simple one.
Is there any prospect of being
able to map a custom domain to
a specific version of an app?
ALON LEVI: Not at present, no.
But that's an interesting
feature [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
we can look into.
Yeah, exactly.
Or have it mapped to a back
end, or have it--
Yeah, that's definitely
something we'd
like to look into.
GREG DALESANDRE: This is an
area where we're actually
looking at right now anyway, of
what's the best way to do
some of that.
And so I'm glad you
mentioned that.
It was something we hadn't
specifically talked about.
ALON LEVI: Good feedback.
Thank you.
GREG DALESANDRE: Thank you.
ALON LEVI: So I guess
that's it for us.
Thank you for attending, and
feel free to find any of us
afterwards.